yes of course he might have prepared
this position
in many years ago but after after that i
think it's
oh magnus accepted oh my god just
can you guys see
okay it's cut off wait i'm gonna have to
lose
okay people are like going crazy
okay you guys should be able to see
i've never abandoned a game that fast in
my life
can you guys see
this is like is this okay do you want me
to resize it somehow
okay thank you thank you thank you thank
you got it got it got i got it don't
worry
got it
yeah this is i'm gonna lose the first
game i to my in my defense i was like
resizing and stuff
now now we can now we can actually begin
okay now i can focus no i was actually
distracted so i'm going to give myself a
little bit of a pass on that game
but this now we're now we have begun the
match
i'm gonna close the chat for a bit guys
and focus
somebody dial myself if uh
the board freezes or something
all right
ah bishop h6 okay i guess that's a
legitimate move
wow really really
[Music]
um
i just read c1 for instance
okay he's got to go back to c7
you gotta take rebecca out on a date
after that one
wait did i just wonder stupid
yeah let's just castle
all right i want to go g5
okay let's go here
wait i can't okay i can give him a check
though
oh
some perpetual maybe
that ideas a bad blunder
yeah i'm playing kind of crappy right
now
yeah okay can't let this slip
so
let's go here
oh i had that oh my goodness i had just
knight f2
don't expect magnus to blender like that
um
still not easy
foreign
yeah he saves it i mean that was not
easy to be completely honest
he had two pawns there i don't know if
that was even winning
yeah we already had this once i think
yeah this is just as bad as the first
time
yeah nothing works
super solid here
let's get some chances some chances
so i guess i take what he wants
h4 makes sense
[Music]
this is interesting though it's not so
easy for him i guess her h1 check
okay john's beautiful
he doesn't see it can't find anything
wow
so
so fast
wow that was burly barely
oh my goodness
[Music]
all right
okay but for the record nobody's we flag
each other so this is not like
you know this is bullet magnus is okay
with it we've already
you know just so nobody thinks this is
some sort of
particularly dirty strategy like we both
do this to each other
on the regular okay i should stop
playing this line though
this is not good e4
wait a minute
or i can try to trap this queen
okay this is fine or not why did i just
allow e4
i guess i can go d4 unbelievable that
was an unbelievable game because i was
so losing
there's the queen yeah i guess that was
a sack
he's got a bunch of stuff for it
engaged in ig3 wins
king h2 i guess we can take
because i can take another one
yes another one in the can
thank you everybody for the subs and
stuff i have the chat closed right now
guys i'm sorry about that i'm just
trying to focus
hope that's okay
okay so he wants knight of four and it's
not a focus so how about
no yeah
you can't even like play the world
champion and see the chat what a scrub
dude like oh my god
i i opened the chat for like a hot
second there just to see what people
were saying
okay so i can't take
this king h2
here
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
i looked at this slime and i don't
remember what i
think
yeah this is there's some piece like
these slack pieces
i just don't remember how to like get
compensation here
it's d5
yeah i can't go into this stuff without
knowing what to do
this position is a mess
absolutely nice which i like because
it's a motto position that's how we do
it in the south
um
do
[Music]
let's go b3
and let's get a lost position or the
other thing with that
how about getting a lost position at the
opening it's a great idea daniel
let's do it get this party started okay
let's take
check here wait actually oh he takes oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i flubbed the opening there
completely
i flopped the opening but it's okay i
can i can still oh
this is nasty no this is rough got this
passer but
it's closing down an exchange here too
much
too much too much i had some counter
play maybe
play those kinds of openings
just take um
let's go
it's an annoying opening playing some
bullets
[Music]
there
[Music]
this is lost a lot of miracles
[Music]
[Music]
i flagged him
unbelievable
me
mmm i assume
people don't really consider this a win
but i don't really consider it a win
but it is bullet guys i i do what i can
i hope nobody's
too angry at that each each person does
what they can
let's beat magnus
berserk thanks for the stuff
he's so slippery too
so slippery
this is over though
another one
okay
let's go c6 to cover the d5 square
eyes maybe i should sack the queen
honestly
just get the d4 square for the night
i can take
obviously winning for white
struggling a little bit
okay good game the game
game art
really okay
i'll sack the piece
not that i really have a choice
where's my compensation yeah this is bad
this is an opening disaster
this is an open disaster
still some
um chances we're not
i guess i can go here
yeah i was over optimistic there
yeah yeah okay
[Music]
oh
yeah this is doing stupid stuff here
starting to do stupid stuff let's go d5
this is a good move though oh
oh
to get the king as quickly as i can
ah he's got this one
okay okay gotta stop the bleeding here
[Music]
[Music]
oh
slight advantage
i'm just going to
[Music]
oh
i have a shot here
okay let's go this line
the bleeding stop the bleeding another
wind is necessary here
see if i can get it done
oh h5 jesus
okay i can't go i should have gone of
course king h1
okay let's continue because you know
because reasons
okay so i shouldn't take that rook i
guess
i still shouldn't take
oh
there
do
let's go
let's go c6
what am i doing this is bad
okay let's go beefy allows b5 which is
weird
i shouldn't have allowed that but still
might be six yeah
this is miserable
yep good game
that
oh he wants this
i guess
all right
so here
yes i'm drinking whiskey while playing
magnus
here under the pond that's what we do
blender ponds blender ponds incorporated
i was briefly reading chat while playing
this is what i should have taken
should have taken that one because now
now he's got the lobster pincer okay
let's go g5 root out the spot
without this one he's gonna go knight f3
surprise it took him that long
got flagging ideas maybe
or not
um
unbelievable i flagged them again okay
this is now actually
okay but okay now it's very good for me
yes yes
it's the luckiest game in history there
as has been like every win basically got
now played every game and
just gotten lucky at the end
maybe there's one game where i outplayed
them
this doesn't prove anything all right
that's weird
let's take
i might have two
takes takes
no i mean this is he's playing after a
tournament i mean
a little bit slower than usual so most
of those games he would have won a
million times
nothing nothing to write home about
magnus and i should not be mentioned in
the same sentence
a monitor
just watch leeches go down
here
what's going on now i don't know
[Music]
yeah but he can't go eat too
he just screwed it up
look at that mate
i mean i know i could take his rook guys
i expected him to block
with his rook
good position
so
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i'm losing a piece here i think
yeah this one's over
i've got three pawns for the piece
though
oh painful one
i should have seen that
people seriously make a big deal out of
the fact that i didn't adopt magnus
all right that's where the bar is at now
i assume
that's where the bar is
is that the expectation
interesting so my point is
it's a little bit hard to meet
expectations then
all right so
yeah i'm gonna lose this one too
just adopt magnus who the f are you i
mean
can't even adopt the world champion come
on
hikara adopted him when he was like two
years old
not playing as well
[Music]
down a piece here
the moment i pre-move you like
[Applause]
i managed to pull out a draw
[Music]
[Music]
i missed it but now he's got this
knight c1 is interesting
um
oh oh oh oh my gosh oh my god
i lost my focus there
your friends ago
yeah lost my focus and i'm pretty much
winning position
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
g5 it's not good
it's just completely losing for black in
the opening
[Music]
how is this caught winning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right step stop the bleeding there
[Music]
yeah these king's indians are not going
well for me though
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
yeah this one's over
[Music]
okay look
a little ton of fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah magnus is terrible losing positions
magnus come on
thinking about it
yeah but this i'm starting to play
very poorly here
just kind of spice things up a little
bit
d5 i was expecting something different
yeah no i'm completely losing to the
grip here
i have to win this one
simple as that
so
just got very unlucky there
i don't know
check me mate your majesty
pull that one out in the end
good position there
d4 has to be good
yeah he's starting to checkmate me here
already
not mean you should be leading the match
by a very long shot i'm getting lucky in
a lot of these games that are flagged
so
all right
okay so if he takes i guess i kind of
have to go for this line
the issue is
so
yeah that was a mistake him
um what's going on here
is this here maybe
yeah i think i'll take this one
[Music]
okay let's go d4 let's go to london
what it is i'm doing here
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
huh i tried my best there
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right oh no no no no i blundered i
forgot the rope was saying
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
see if i can retake the lead this game
[Music]
some questions
[Music]
[Music]
oh my goodness that was a mouse look
damaged
foreign
oh oh oh i didn't need to do that
sloppy move transmission but still might
be good in the end
oh no no no no
[Music]
oh my goodness that was just winning
somehow it created
i chances vienna was already lost
acceptable
and i'm just wondering every move now
[Music]
so
wow flag there he couldn't make a move
okay okay good good good that's a good
draw stop the bleeding
just kind of gotta win a game here at
some point
let's go here i'm gonna have to go
pretty soon guys
i have lessons
somehow he's fine i mean all his faces
are on the back
but he's totally fine only magnus does
that kind of stuff let's go here
so funny repetition
blenders
that's very bad
so
[Music]
all right good one let's go
[Music]
yeah i just lost without a fight can't
do that just faster than fight
without any fight okay
typical magnus positions here
please
not the best technique
again take the other phone obviously
please explain
please
please explain
please explain
[Music]
please explain
please express
[Music]
do
[Applause]
pawn could be a weakness later
i don't know what's going on here
[Music]
thank you
this is the one
please explain
you can probably just take
it's going fine
[Music]
magnus is not using a fake account i am
capable of occasionally
hanging with these guys
[Music]
believe it or not
we've got no time here
and of course i have one i mean
literally the only move come on
i can make it oh this one maybe
there we go e5 big this one but
unacceptable
the blunder like that
yes let's go let's go let's go another
another one
no i don't have time guys i got a ghost
and i mean i didn't expect this
i didn't expect magnus to be online i
can't clear my entire schedule just
you know just to supply them
unfortunately i'm sorry
after a living folks
so
do you want to go here i've still got
time though
[Music]
sure can we win another one all right we
equalize the score good
i can't believe
[Music]
see if i can take the lead of this game
[Music]
see if i can extend the lead of this
[Music]
game
[Music]
all right i forgot he is this thing i
completely forgot he was cheating
distracted yeah no
see that's that's one of my problems i
like can't hold on
i do need to go to the bathroom but
sorry okay this is okay now for me
situation is stabilized a little bit
that's five
i'm gonna get the knife back
let's try to trade
[Music]
once queen a3
this line is called the verbator the
least
all right it means something in dutch
but i don't remember what
it means you messed up the line daniel
that's what it means i think i'm
supposed to take actually
[Music]
okay this is okay actually i've got this
nice bishop this nice night but
i don't think it's quite enough for the
pawn
yeah it's this type
a little bit more piece coordination
mess this up
how do i do this
maybe even winning that b-forma was nice
by magnus
shadows in my face
clearly on sound
[Music]
[Music]
i thought i could do this
[Music]
oh
okay let's go here
that's an annoying typical magnus
so
oh my gosh i just didn't
yes
so
so
okay
come on what are you doing here
maybe like this
yeah this is the draw i mean i don't
want to go for it there it's too risky
i'm supposed to have d5 here this is
good for white for black
oh he wants bishop d4
do
crap
ah he goes there
i'm lucky there thank you chest center
for the raid
i don't think this works but it's fine
at the very least
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here
it's gonna play
just gonna try to force a draw here
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so all right
i should pull out a draw there
thanks everybody for all the subs
appreciate it
so
thanks
see if i can move to 8 30 for my lesson
but not later than that
not too slightly what am i doing
so you should not have taken that okay
[Music]
yeah that's been the whole match i mean
every basically every win has been due
to
due to time so this is again pyrrhic
victory
there's pure luck there i think he's
slower than usual for some reason
you
let me know if we can do 8 30.
just for today
okay thank you thank you thank you
perfect i'm really sorry
i don't want this won't happen again
okay i'll let magnus know in eight i
have 30 more minutes
yeah i'm sure he's sleepy and stuff so
there's no way i would beat him if he
was on farm
susan pogar said i've never beaten a
healthy opponent
[Music]
heaven forbid
to
i really need to be badly
do
i'm just lucky there he missed a fork
hope you guys are all enjoying the match
having a good time that's the most
important
all right
thanks everybody for the support i'm
sorry if i missed subs and stuff i'm
sure there were subs
that i missed but thanks
foreign
unbelievable
we already had one like this that i lost
um now i can maybe take
take
i've got some fonts here i don't know
this is not subpar but it's interesting
so
[Music]
um
oh he's disabled chad i can't tell him
oh wait no i can
wait
i said i've got 30 more minutes this is
cool okay great
i accidentally said have fun
sorry i distracted him so i wanted to
wait
no that was an accident i swear that was
an accident
i swear that was an accident i my hands
are like shaking so
i mistyped it
have fun i used to have when i was
little i used to have this little teddy
bear
um where you know you could press it and
it made noises and stuff
um and one of them was
like have a good day
have fun it's kind of like that
i ain't having funny jerk
[Applause]
so
so
so
oh yeah yeah yeah this is bad just gonna
do some damage control here
this is pretty rough
okay that gives me chances
so
so
oh my goodness splendored okay fortunate
with a pawn
thank god
okay thank heavens i had that uh knight
f3 move
this is a hot mess
there's queen bee throughout the rugby
and i'm okay
and now i'm in trouble forgot he is
thank god another draw
that's a bad move
[Music]
probably this
yeah but okay i should probably take
ah he's got this
this is not good
now why would i do that
oh i was winning there why didn't i just
take
i was just winning i don't know why i
tried to be dirty instead
oh my goodness that's so stupid
i think i was i miscounted the ponds i
thought it was my only chance oh my
goodness that's
that's that's bad
it's embarrassing
i mean that's just an embarrassment wow
unbelievable that was a crazy
miscalculation
anyways moving on
and now i'm losing again that's the
[Music]
problem
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just gonna play passive
oh here is very bad very very bad
[Music]
[Music]
alright
yeah this is another loss i think unless
oh i have this move that's an important
move
[Music]
not good
so
[Music]
bad i gotta stabilize but i'm just
playing worse and worse
do
[Music]
you
yeah okay
sorry i accidentally exited out of it i
accidentally exited out of the game
yeah i'm getting nervous i re-challenged
him
okay
yeah not good
[Music]
completely winning there
yeah oh my gosh this is just terrible
yeah i lost my concentration maybe i can
pull out some sort of a miracle here
[Music]
yeah just every move is a blunder now
[Music]
[Music]
this is a wonderful position
until now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why did i do that
let's go
[Music]
still bad and i just like lost the
threat of the match a little bit
do
freaking go let's go
thank you chez dojo for [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
so
let's go
should be a good position
my
oh he's got quincy
okay
no no
no
no
oh my goodness he just sees these ideas
you
i shouldn't go for the flag there
last one probably guys i gotta go
i'm fine
okay last two
last two guys
what am i doing
do
all right gotta win this one
try match time match all right thanks
magnus
oh my gosh that's crazy
all right oh my gosh
all right that was a great match that
was a great match i got lucky i i feel a
little bit better because
some of those reflect all right that was
a great one
that was a great one um sorry i had to
run guys
probably we'll put put this one up on
[Music]
youtube